hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
freeze-drying solutions for your lab
presented by Meghan Zimmerman product
manager and Jenny's from senior
application specialist lab compco
corporation I'm sorry grant a man of
labrys and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by lab Rouge
and sponsored by lab Congo for more
information on our sponsor please visit
lab Congo comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by kick clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenters Meghan Zimmerman and
Jenny sprung Meghan Zimmerman is a
product manager for freeze dryers and
evaporators at lab Kongo corporation she
has a BA in biology
prior to joining lab camcos she spent
several years in laboratory working on
research in Pediatric Gastroenterology
and agricultural sciences jenny and
earned her degree in biology with minor
in chemistry from the University of
Wisconsin
Parkside graduating in 1997 prior to
starting at lab panco she worked at SC
Johnson wax in sensory
Marketing after graduating she started
in an R&D laboratory working with
cleaning products for the home in 1998
she moved to Kansas City and started
working with lab Congo in the marketing
department as a product specialist she
was promoted to a product manager
position overseeing the development of
evaporation lysyl is asian products and
glassware washer lines currently she is
a senior application specialist with
emphasis on evaporation and life of
civilization glass player washers water
and forensic products but she also
covers all lamps lab comm code 17
product lines Megan you may now present
your presentation
today we'll be talking about freeze
drying solutions for your lab
start by discussing a general overview
of the freeze drying process followed by
how to select a freeze dryer to meet
your needs then I'll pass things off to
Jenny and she'll talk about how to
develop a free of protocol freeze dry
and challenging samples and
troubleshooting first we'll start by
discussing some common terms you might
hear in free string freeze drying is the
process of removing moisture from a
frozen product using a vacuum another
term you might hear is i authorization
which is just another word for freeze
drying that is derived from the greek
word solvent loving my alpha life
samples are easily rehydrated making it
a great process for sample preparation
because you can easily resuspend your
sample sublimation is also a word you'll
hear when talking about freeze drying
this is the process and freeze drying in
which solvents pass directly from a
solid base to a gas phase giving
freeze-dried samples such great
preservation properties because you are
bypassing the liquid phase the rate at
which sublimation occurs is dependent on
temperature and pressure
this graph shows what's happening to
your sample when you freeze drying for
sublimation to occur you need to have a
cold enough temperature and a deep
enough vacuum for your sample to go from
a solid to a gas if either of these
things doesn't occur the sample will
actually evaporate and not get the
preservation properties that you would
during sublimation the pressure and
temperature critical components of
freeze drying when priests trying it is
important to cool the material below its
triple point which is shown on the graph
the triple point is the highest
temperature at which the solid and
liquid phases of material can go it's
codesys
below this point ensures that
sublimation rather than evaporation will
occur next we are going to talk about
the requirements needed for the freeze
drying process the first requirement is
that you must have a pre frozen samples
before you start your run when you put
the frozen sample on the free stringer
it will be subject to melting until the
appropriate vacuum level is established
you might see this melting occur with
older vacuum pumps or pumps that aren't
working well because it will take longer
for the vacuum to pull down so the
vacuum level and how quickly it pulls
down are critical to the freeze drying
process another requirement of freeze
drying is that you need a collector that
is 15 to 20 degrees colder than the
samples freezing points by nature water
molecules from your sample will want to
move to the coldest spot in this system
the condenser coil this natural
migration of water molecules is called
cryo pumping the next requirement for
freeze drying is having a deep vacuum
with a minimum requirement of 0.002
millibar this is necessary because the
vacuum pump establishes negative
pressure forcing free-flowing water
molecules that have left the sample by
sublimation to evacuate from the
environment around the sample and
trafford travel to the condenser coil
the last requirement for freeze drying
is having energy in the form of heat
while not obvious to a lot of people the
lyophilization process is essentially a
heat transfer process for example with
flask freeze drying the flask is hanging
at room temperature and the ambient heat
from the room is what's driving the
process in general the more heat you are
able to apply to your samples the faster
your run will go however not all samples
can take the same amount of heat input
if you add too much heat to certain
samples you could cause your sample to
no
images show the difference between
uncontrolled keys and control teeth with
uncontrolled ye'd the flask is receiving
ambient heat from the air in the room
making it hard to control for samples in
the pharmaceutical industry or
production sample people will typically
use a tray dryer so they can apply
controlled heat to their samples
when you're freeze drawing there are
three stages that occur first is the pre
freezing stage where you start with the
completely frozen sample this is
followed by primary drying and then
secondary training for many laboratories
there isn't much difference between
these two stages but for pharmaceuticals
or for more sophisticated free show runs
there is a very distinct difference on
this graph is showing a freestyle run
throughout the three stages of the
process the blue line shows the shelf
temperature while the green line shows
the temperature of the sample
grass begins showing the freezing of the
product and when the sample matches the
shelf temperature freezing of the sample
has occurred this sample is then this
stage is then held for a while to ensure
the entire sample is completely frozen
after the hold you see the shelf
temperatures start to climb in primary
drying however the sample temperature no
longer correlates to the rise and shelf
temperature this is because the sample
is undergoing evaporative cooling which
suppresses the temperature this is also
what allows you to add heat during
primary drying with the addition of this
heat you are increasing the rate of
sublimation and shortening your run
primary drying continues into your shelf
temperature and sample temperature meet
for most laboratories that are planning
to resuspend their samples this is the
point when they would typically end the
run with their samples containing about
seven to eight percent moisture however
for end-users who are preparing their
samples for long term preservation they
will continue to run into secondary
drying
secondary drying is where water
molecules that are bound to sample are
released with the additional heat in
this last stage you are able to drive
those bound water molecules out of your
sample and are left with about 2%
moisture for more sophisticated freeze
drying you can send your samples off to
companies where they will watch the
freeze drying process under a microscope
they can then tell you your samples
triple point and what amount of heat
input would be good for your run in
general most plants will just
guesstimate the heat input fine-tuning
their process to develop an optimal
application run now we are going to talk
through each of the three stages in a
little more detail in the pre freezing
stage if you are freezing your sample in
a flask you want to make sure your
sample you're freezing your sample in a
way that gives you the greatest chance
for efficiency during your run the first
example on the Left shows stub freezing
which is just keeping your sample on a
flat surface and it's not a good way to
freeze your sample the example in the
middle is called plan freezing where you
keep your sample at an angle while you
freeze it by doing this you're
increasing the surface area of your
sample which helps reduce your overall
run time the example on the right shell
breathing is the most optimal way to
freeze your sample especially when
you're working with large volumes which
shell freezing does is roll the sample
while it's freezing and it's very cold
solution to create a thin coating over
the entire surface of the plaque this
gives you the largest surface area and
reduces the amount of sample the water
molecules have to move through during
freeze drying once your sample is frozen
and you start your freeze dryer you
begin primary drying as you can see in
the picture
there is so much evaporative cooling
happening during the step that you will
get frost build up on the outside of
your flask this is a good indication
that your freeze drying process is going
well if you see the frost start to melt
as well as your sample this is
indicating that there is a problem with
your run at this point you are no longer
freeze drying and your sample is
undergoing evaporation when we are able
to
control heat input in primary drain the
temperature your sample is that plays an
important role in your run while some
samples can take a lot of heat other
samples don't do well with heat input
the example shown is from a paper where
they were studying the effects of freeze
drying same sample at different
temperatures the example on the bottom
left shows the result of a glob cake a
cake is what you call the remaining
product after you freeze dry your sample
with this run the sample melted and
underwent evaporation instead of
sublimation and the shelf temperature
was set at minus 10 degrees Celsius and
the product was at minus 15 degrees
Celsius the example on the bottom range
is a result of a partially collapsed
cake with this run they adjusted their
shelf temperature to minus 15 degrees C
and had a product temperature of minus
20 degrees C with the last example on
the top right they adjusted their shelf
temperature to minus 20 degrees C with a
product temperature of minus 25 degrees
C and had a finished product with an
excellent cake so you can see that even
though none of these runs had a
difference of more than 5 degrees
Celsius from one to the next there was
still a very big difference in how the
final product turned out this is why you
will have to fine-tune your process to
develop a protocol that would give you
the best cake unless you plan to send
your samples off to be tested after
primary drying is complete you move into
secondary drain where you releasing two
remaining water molecules that are bound
to the sample in order to complete
secondary drains you need a freeze dryer
that has shelves so you can apply
additional heat to your samples and get
the moisture content down to about 2%
for long-term storage of your samples
you will want to complete secondary
drying and you'll want to also stopper
or seal your samples under a vacuum by
stopping your samples under vacuum you
avoid exposing your samples to the
moisture in the air when you open the
door another way to achieve long-term
storage is to flame seal your sample
samples and ampules before the vacuum is
released next time
to talk about selecting a free Strayer
that meets the needs of your lab
the first thing you'll want to think
about is who all will be using the
freeze dryer this is purchased just for
your lab or multiple groups be using the
freeze dryer find out what kind of
samples each person plans to use the
unit for looking at the types of
solvents and acids that make up their
samples also determine who will be
responsible for maintenance such as
cleaning the coils and performing oil
changes in the vacuum pump this will
help to keep your freeze dryer and
vacuum pump in optimal working
conditions
choosing the right materials for your
freeze dryer is important when making
your selection many solvents used in
samples can attack plastic and rubber
components which cause vacuum leaks over
time because of this it's important that
you know what kind of solvents and acids
everyone will be using because you want
to make sure the samples will be
compatible with the materials of your
freeze dryer
knowing what kind of solvents will be
used you'll also want to determine the
collector temperature you need keeping
in mind that the temperature should be
15 to 20 degrees colder than the
freezing point of your sample free
Striders typically come in collector
temperatures of minus 50 minus 84 and
minus 105 degrees Celsius
you also need to determine the collector
size of your freeze dryer freeze dryers
are described by their eyes holding
capacity so if you're looking at a 4.5
liter freeze dryer that means it can
hold four and a half liters of ice
before needing to be defrosted this does
not mean that you can put four and a
half liters of sample on the freestar
but instead you would put about half
that volume on there to accommodate all
the vapors that will come off your
samples when you start your run the next
thing that you need to determine is the
type of vacuum pump you mean
freeze-drying requires that your pump be
able to reach 100 microns with the
displacement of at least 98 liters per
minute
when selecting your freeze dryer you
also need to consider the accessories
you'll need besides offering flasks and
serum bottles
we also offer items like - Brax and
micro plate holders with micro plates
since you're working with such a small
volume of sample it's very easy for that
sample to start melting quickly with our
micro plate older you can place your
micro plate on holder while your freeze
drying your sample and keep it on there
during your run to help keep the sample
frozen while your vacuum is going down
another thing to consider when selecting
a freeze dryer is the coil design with
our internal coil design we are able to
provide coldest possible temperatures
and are superior and capturing solvents
coming off your samples compared to an
external coil design that is on the
outside of the condenser
some other things to consider when
selecting a freeze dryer what kind of
controls does your freestyle need what
do you need to get the appropriate data
end results through your run do you need
your free starter to meet cGMP standards
do you need a free starter with shelves
to pre-crease your samples
controlling your freestyle what kind of
software and programming do you need how
are you accessing your data with our new
my own work software you're able to
download your data to a USB flash drive
or use an Ethernet connection to send
your run data straight to your computer
through a one-way connection we also
offer remote notification with the
ability to configure the types of alerts
that are sent to your email
since breeze dry runs can sometimes last
for days leaving you wondering how your
samples are doing while you're away from
the lab you can have alerts sent to your
phone showing you the parameters of the
run giving you some peace of mind while
you're away a vacuum control valve is
another important feature to have in
your fridge dryer by being able to set
the vacuum level you're able to speed
your run time a certain Selden's many
people think if they pull the deepest
vacuum it will speed their run but that
isn't the case having your sample set at
point to millibar it's actually the most
efficient vacuum settings and point
detection is another feature to consider
if your freeze drying in class often
times it can be difficult to tell if
your sample is done which leads people
to sometimes take their samples off too
soon going to realize the run was
incomplete and causing them to start to
run all over or they're leaving their
samples on for much longer than they
really need just to ensure that their
run is finished wasting time and energy
the freeze dryer is using our endpoint
detection helps you avoid both of these
outcomes by alerting you to when your
samples have achieved the level of
dryness that you've set
now I'm going to pass things over to
Jenny where she'll discuss developing a
protocol great Thank You Megan now we'll
start talking about your specific
protocols this is a great opportunity
for you to ask questions so that we can
respond to you as we go through this
process when developing a protocol as
Megan mentioned there are three steps
you have pre freezing primary drying and
secondary drying as long as your samples
are 100% frozen you are ready to move on
to primary drying however a lot of
people feel like their samples are
frozen but they're really not ready to
go on and they'll start seeing melt back
immediately
the protocol we're looking at on this
slide is done in a tray dryer which will
do all three steps for you you'll load
your liquid sample typically in serum
vials or on bulk trays you'll run the
pre freezing process at a set
temperature once the samples are
completely frozen then you're going to
start pulling a vacuum and adding a
little bit of controlled heat to those
samples to do your main drying process
from there you go into secondary drying
which is still under vacuum but adding
additional heat and then when the
samples are done you'll you'll pull them
off you'll either stop or under vacuum
or you'll unload them through the door
if you're doing the process in flasks on
a standard port type freeze dryer you'll
pre freeze either in a shell freezer or
in a standalone freezer attach them to a
port pull a vacuum and your heat is
going to come from the room temperature
there's also heated product shelves that
you can do this secondary drying part
but not the pre freezing so during the
freeze dry process there are a lot of
different options in different freeze
dryers to choose from it really depends
on what you're trying to attempt as well
as your budget to optimize your lavel
ization process there's a few things
that you can do
first of all never overfill your
container if you have a 600 mil flask
you don't want to put more than about
200 milliliters into that flask what
this is going to allow is greater
surface area of those samples for faster
freeze drying it's also going to prevent
breaking the flasks during the pre
freeze process so it will be helpful if
you can just fill to 1/3 full also many
users will use test tubes inside of our
flasks and that's a great way to get
your more surface area as well as run
multiple samples inside of one flask
when you're looking at your different
pumps there are three different types to
choose from you have a standard pump you
have a hybrid pump and you have a scroll
pump there's pros and cons to each and
every one of those pumps but to go over
them briefly
typically the rotary vane pump is going
to be for aqueous based samples the
scroll pump will be for solvents and
acids and the scroll pump is a dry pump
so that can be used for pretty much
anything and it will not require oil
changes you do not need to oversize a
pump or you also don't want to
undersized a pump so keep that in mind a
lot of people think bigger is better but
that's not always the case in
lyophilization if you are unsure what
size pump to use feel free to give us a
call and we're happy to help you
the pre free step is actually the most
important step in your freeze-dry
process you want greater surface area
because the more surface area you get
the faster your freeze-drying will
become if you can shell freeze
that's the best way to do it but another
option is slant freezing just in a
standard freezer keep in mind that
freeze drying starts from the top down
once that top layer is dry it makes it
more difficult for those molecules to
move out so you'll definitely want to
get more surface area to prevent that
and you do want to pre freeze to the
samples freezing point or lower again
you just want to make sure that that
sample is 100% frozen for the freeze dry
process the rate of pre freezing is very
important
fast pre freezing can create small ice
crystals where controlled cooling can
actually create larger ice crystals the
larger the ice crystals the faster your
freeze dry process will be so depending
on what you want your outcome to be if
you're doing sample prep and you need
this done quickly fast pre freezing
might be preferred over a controlled
rate freezing if you want the samples to
freeze dry quicker then you may want to
do some controlled freezing with those
samples
the next step once your samples are 100%
frozen you want to go into primary
drying and the primary drying is going
to take the longest portion of your
freeze dry process during primary drying
many people think especially when
they're using a controlled shelf type
system that colder is better but it's
actually just the opposite if you can
add heat during that primary drying
process you're going to have faster dry
dry time and then you'll have faster
secondary drying so overall the rate of
that freeze dried sample will go quicker
if you can add heat however keep in mind
if you add too much heat you're going to
melt your sample and the opposite is
going to be true so just watch for your
samples watch the melting if they do
melt you can actually pre freeze them
again and start over in many cases it's
just very dependent on your samples
and you can also have control of your
vacuum pressure sometimes if you have
too deep of a vacuum it does not allow
those molecules to move out so
controlling your vacuum is an important
viable ization process as well
a lot of times when we see freeze dryer
setup they'll be in front of a window or
in a tiny room and it'll be very warm in
that room because the freeze dryer is
going to create some heat on its own so
you do need to make sure that you have
ambient room temperature of about 22
degrees C make sure that the room is not
too small a medium sized room is good
make sure that your system is not set up
in front of a very sunny window so for
example if you live in the south and
you're putting your freeze dryer and it
all Kove with a window in it where the
sun is shining directly onto that freeze
dryer it's going to be very difficult
for that freeze dryer to maintain a
temperature but it's also going to
create melt back of your sample during
the winter you don't want the unit under
a heat vent because again you're you're
blowing keep down onto a frozen sample
and that could have issues with melt
back of your samples itself if you are
doing the pre free step in a separate
freezer you don't want that freezer
three buildings down where you have to
walk two miles to get it to the freeze
dryer because obviously by the time it
gets to the freeze dryer it could be
melted so a couple things to keep in
mind and I have seen examples of all of
these so when I talk about these
examples if they're not they're not made
up there are real-life examples your
final outcome sometimes you get a very
pretty
powder a pretty cake or a pretty outcome
but sometimes you don't every once in a
while you'll have you'll need to add
bulking agents or stabilizers if your
sample is prone to being degraded by
freezing you may have to use a leiyo
protectant to help against that pre
freezing step
next we're going to talk a little bit
about the C GMP requirements and
according to the FDA that if you want a
cgmp piece of equipment that's actually
done on your end so you can take the
piece of equipment and make it fit in
need of your GMP requirements what a
manufacturer can do for you is we can
offer you the materials of construction
we can give you the test reports that we
have done on your freeze dryer based on
your serial number to let you know that
it did pass all of our internal QA
specifications we also offer all the
manuals the documents the videos
everything that you need we do i qo q we
offer it at no charge
PQ would be done by an outside
corporation that you would contact to
come in to finish up your qualification
but we are always happy to help in any
of the steps and whatever you need to
make sure that your freeze dryer can be
used with your cgmp standards
there are multiple challenging samples
and as freeze-drying
evolved into a sample prep step versus a
long-term storage step we're seeing more
and more challenging samples one of them
that I have seen is called tert-butyl
alcohol so on paper tert-butyl looks
like it should freeze dry fine it has a
great eutectic temperature there should
be no issues however when you actually
freeze dry it you don't get a nice
powder you actually get a gummy type
sample so very difficult to reconstitute
you may have issues keeping it keeping
it dry because you've already kind of
got that that gummy wet that you can't
get totally dry so as a sample prep step
the tert-butyl is fine as long as you're
going to use it right away but obviously
for long-term storage it's already
starting to rehydrate so you're going to
have issues with that long-term another
product that is very difficult to dry
our alcohols alcohol such as ethanol and
methanol have a very low freezing price
freezing temperature and as Megan noted
you must have a temperature differential
between your collector and your samples
freezing point of about 20 degrees the
for example ethanol has a freezing point
of minus 117 degrees which would mean
that you would need a freeze dryer of
minus one hundred and thirty-seven
degrees there's not a freezer out there
that can go that low so how do you get
around if you need to freeze dry
lyophilization I'm sorry freeze dry
ethanol samples what you'll do is you
must use a minus 105 freeze dryer and
you must dilute those samples to ten
percent or less 10 percent is the spot
that we have found in our testing where
that sample does not melt back but it
does go through the freeze dry process
so 10 percent is your magic number
whenever you're doing alcohol based
samples and you have to have a minus 105
degree freeze dryer
DMSO is another solvent that we're
seeing more and more often
DMSO is difficult because that solvent
just the solvent alone is going to start
attacking rubber and plastic components
and anytime you have a anytime you have
anything under vacuum such as a lieth
eliezer it's got to use rubber
components for the gaskets and the
o-rings to keep that under a deep vacuum
so what we recommend with DMSO is it
will freeze dry fine just watch all of
your rubber and plastic components and
replace as needed we've also found that
sugars and salts cause a lower eutectic
temperature so we do recommend a cascade
model we also have seen with samples
such as fruit that the sugars bypassed
the collector and they could get into
your pump so a hepa filter in line with
the pump is recommended again with soil
samples and we do recommend a HEPA
filter with those as well because what
happens with soil samples is during the
dry process they could become very
powdery and they're going to bypass a
collector and go right into the vacuum
pump so be very careful with soil
samples they're great they freeze very
very nicely same with Leafs tissues they
freeze dry nicely just watch the
composition of those samples if you need
a HEPA filter to protect the pump that's
something that can be easily added in
line if you have whole fruit samples or
whole animal samples that just fish it's
best to either homogenize the fruits and
vegetables or if you can poke holes in
the tissues of your animals or poke
holes in the fruit if your freeze drying
for example grapes or blueberries poking
holes through those skins will be
helpful
a big part of freeze-drying is going to
be troubleshooting if your samples won't
stay frozen during the freeze dry
process there's a couple things that you
can look at make sure that you have the
correct freeze dryer as Megan mentioned
you must have a temperature differential
between the freeze dryer and the samples
eutectic temperature for example with
the Seton nitrile which has a eutectic
temperature of minus 42 you must have a
freeze dryer that is minus 62 degrees or
colder in this case we would recommend a
cascade model which reaches minus 84
degrees if your samples are small or in
plastic containers
those tend to melt a lot quicker even
walking from your freezer to your freeze
dryer and if your samples have alcohols
in them alcohols have a very low
freezing point which require a minus 105
degree freeze dryer as well as diluting
those alcohols to 10 percent or less
also take a look at the pressure of your
freeze dryer because if your pump is not
pulling correct pressure that could also
lead to melting back of your samples
sometimes a sample can be very
lightweight or very powdery and they'll
get pulled out by the vacuum so using
filter paper or parafilm is a way around
that it you'll still notice that your
samples might pop up in the tube but if
you can put some pair of them over at
least you won't lose your sample if your
samples are taking a long time to lie
applies your shelf temperature might be
too cold your sample may be too thick
or you might be somehow blocking a vial
if you have a vial inside of a flask you
may not have enough headspace to
encourage those molecules to leave your
vial
a couple things to check if you're
noticing that you're having a vacuum
level that's not what it used to be make
sure none of your gaskets have cracks in
them or any dirt on them sometimes we'll
see dust or dirt on the gaskets and even
little specks of it can prevent pulling
a deep vacuum so check your gaskets
check all of your valves and always do
an oil change if you're unsure when the
last oil change was it's probably time
to do another oil change oil changes
really are dependent on how often you
use the freeze dryer as well as what
solvents you're using in your free
Schreyer because if solvents are
bypassing and getting into your pump you
will have issues we also recommend doing
a purge on your pump before and after
running your freeze dryer if your
samples are not sealing correctly and
this would be in terms of a trade dryer
where you're going to be stopping under
vacuum you need to make sure that you
have your vials evenly distributed on
the Shelf to make sure that you can get
good stopper rain
if the final product looks different
each and every time there's a couple
reasons for that different room
temperature so if you're going from a
summer run to a winter run obviously
your room temperatures are going to be a
little bit different as well as the
dryness in your air so that can actually
affect the outcome of your sample how
pure your solvents are going in in the
percent of your active ingredient that
can all change the outcome of your
sample if you want a cake versus a
powder you do have to watch kind of what
you're doing if you are using different
types of solvents some people choose to
use a keeper solvent with these to make
sure that they look fine coming out but
it's really a matter of trial and error
and what you're trying to get is an
outcome
equipment maintenance the number one
thing to watch for on your freeze dryer
is your vacuum pump the freeze dryer
will alert you after 1,000 hours to do
an oil change but some people may need
to do an oil change after each run but
it's very dependent on your solvents and
how well you're keeping up with your
freeze dryer and the maintenance on the
freeze dryer itself a hybrid pump is a
two-in-one pump so the hybrid pump is
actually going to be cleaning out the
oil during the run we're a scroll pump
is going to be an oil-free pump so the
maintenance is very minimum and there
are no oil changes for a scroll palm a
rotary vane pump is a standard pump is
the pump that most people are familiar
with but they do require more oil
changes
the pump that you're looking at right
here is a pump that was run on a freeze
dryer with water samples only however
the user never did an oil change the
samples were melting back and the water
got into the pump and was allowed to sit
in the vacuum pump for a long period of
time creating the rust that you're
looking at obviously that pump is not
fixable at this point but this is this
is very common and this is what can
happen to your pump if you don't perform
enough oil changes
what when I mentioned that we recommend
a purge that's where the gas ballast
comes into play so anytime you have an
oil pump
there's a gas ballast on that pump
typically you're going to see the gas
ballast settings for 0 1 & 2 during a
run you want the gas Bella set at zero
to get full vacuum but when you're done
with the system and you shut it down and
your samples are all removed you want to
you want to get that system vacuum tight
put the gas ballast to 2 and run that
pump at full speed for about 15 minutes
after the process that's going to do
what we call a purge and it's going to
purge the contaminants out of your oil
by leaking air into that oil allowing
that whale to get really hot and getting
rid of those contaminants that will save
the life of your pump
that is it for the presentation if there
are any questions we would love to hear
from you and now is the time to ask them
Thank You Megan and Jenny for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for let's
get started our first question is you
mentioned optimum pressure is 0.2 mbar
what shelfs temperature is optimal and
are the two related
that's a great question we do discuss
the optimal pressure in terms of your
specific sample types so depending on
what you're doing
typically aqueous base 0.2 millibar is
is a great starting point in terms of
the shelf
temperature what you do need to keep in
mind is what your specific sample is so
again if it's aqueous samples then you
would want to set the shelf temperature
to just below your eutectic temperature
or your freezing point in terms of the
primary drying so when you're initially
starting but if you go into the
secondary drying you can actually add a
little bit more heat to continually
drive off the sample the rest of the
moisture so it's really very dependent
on what your specific sample is again
for aqueous samples you probably want to
start at at maybe minus five but if
you're looking at more of a say an HPLC
sample that has some estate a nitrile in
it that will have a freezing point of
minus 42 if you start it too high you're
going to melt back that sample so it's
very dependent on your specific sample
in order for us to give you kind of an
idea of where to set that shelf
temperature at I'm happy to help you
with your specific sample offline if you
want to email one of us or I can shoot
you an email as well
thank you for that answer the next
question is for Jenny
Jenny I have a new bio fertilizer and
have not gotten it sent up setup yet if
I have a question
can I contact you later absolutely yep
we're always here for you just email or
call we also have live chat if you
prefer to do live chat so however you
want to do it I am happy to help you
thank you and the next question is well
my current vacuum pump work with lab
Congo freeze dryer
um that's always a good question and it
really we would need to know the
specifications on that palms if it's a
diaphragm based pump it will not work so
it must be a rotary vane based pump or a
scroll pump and one thing that I always
remind people is that the pump gets
plugged into the actual freeze dryer
itself so you can use it in automatic
mode if the plug does not match with our
plug then you'll have to plug it into
the wall in automatic mode will not work
great thank you for that answer the next
question is how can I seal under vacuum
without buying a stopper ring tray dryer
that's a really great great question and
you know stop bringing trade writers are
used for for individuals that are
freeze-drying really large volumes of
samples and so we do offer a few other
options that include our mini stop ring
chamber and a clear stop ring chamber
and that are used for just if you're
doing maybe a handful of serum bottles
and as well as our ampule pod with the
ampule pod you would connect that to a
port on your manifold like if you were
using a flask and then when those
samples are finished before you release
your vacuum you would flame seal the
ampule closed to keep it and keep it
ready for long-term storage
okay great thank you our next question
is how does end zone endpoint detection
work
so with our end zone endpoint detection
and this is used when your freeze-drying
in flask and you're able to take a an
empty port on your manifold
and insert a probe into that port and
then you take a separate probe and
insert it into your freeze-dry flask
through the lid and then before you
start your run you set a level of
dryness so a user selected level and
when the level of dryness has been
achieved and you are alerted through
email that your samples are finished
great thank you
our next question is we find some time
to time just differences on the
appearance of the cakes within a run
what can be done what what can be the
reason of that
Megan do you have this one
um you know it's up to you all right
yeah I my phone actually just blacked
out so I just want to make sure that I
can hear you okay so you're you're
talking about the cracked cakes is that
correct
you know I don't know but I believe
that's what they are asking yes okay
okay great so when you're freeze dry and
you have to keep in mind that you're not
you may or may not get the same outcome
each and every time depending on where
that sample is located if it's on a
shelf and say you have some of those
samples on a shelf towards the middle of
the shelf which are going to be more
insulated or towards the front of the
shelf where you're going to get more UV
light so you're gonna get more radiant
heat on those samples you may get a
different outcome each and every time it
could also be the difference between if
you have too much if you have a more
active in one sample than another sample
that could also have a different outcome
so it's normal to see a cracked cake I
know it's not as pretty as a nice
powdery cake but that is normal and
typically when you check the samples
activity after the process you'll find
that the activity is the same
great thank you and let me ask you um
what special precaution should be taken
to lies the enzyme solution samples okay
so in terms of your specific enzyme and
as you'll notice everything is very
specific to your sample so when I'm
talking it's kind of a general overview
but your specific example it will depend
now some enzymes can be freeze sensitive
which means that they get damaged during
the pre freeze process so you will want
to use a leiyo protectant in that case
to protect those enzymes some enzymes
are fine being frozen and there's no
issues but they may have a heat issue
after the sample is freeze-dried and
you're going into secondary drying so
you really do need to know your your
enzyme and what it can and cannot handle
in terms of lyophilizer
okay and then what are the main reasons
for some cracked cakes being along and
with good cake anything to do with the
show well yep and I actually answered
that one earlier it really is dependent
on the outcome and it looks like we've
had that question multiple times so what
I think might be the best is if possible
I will email each of you who have asked
that question and we can talk more
specifically about your samples
themselves okay great um thank you again
Megan and Jenny do you have any final
comments for our audience
you know we really just want to thank
everybody for taking the time to call in
today
Oh before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today or those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor lab
Congo for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through January of 2019
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you and until next time
goodbye